Your body is made up of many things - such as this cell - an indispensable component,
Make up you... that is, you! Also, in every cell in your body, there is about
At least ten microbes that are essential to your life. Serious, unique
The array of billions of microbes are on your body, you are in life
Pick them up through the mouth, ears and other parts. meaning is,
You in your heart are just a small part of what makes up you.
We call it the microbial system, and these small creatures have about 22 million of them belonging to their DNA.
Genes, which not only allow them to survive, but also control hundreds of programs in your body.
They help you digest food and maintain the health of your immune system.
They can even regulate hunger and make you feel full. Think there is pressure? They also make chemicals for this -
In fact, mice that live in a sterile environment without these microorganisms
The effect on coping with stress is worse than that of ordinary mice.
Have you heard of faecal transplantation? This is real! Some diseases are caused by
Lack of diverse microbial populations, making individuals susceptible to infection.
It has been found that transplanting cultures of healthy human feces to
The patient's gut to treat these diseases is more effective than any antibiotic. Scientists have discovered that
When the microbiota of lean mice are transplanted to obese mice, they are amazingly
Lose weight more effectively, even when their diet remains the same. These creatures
Very important to you, even in the future, doctors may diagnose
Your microbiota is not yours.
But then there is crazy protection - although your cell is just a small part of you,
But in fact you can change another 90%. Unlike genes that your parents inherit,
The food you eat will affect your microbiota.
Foods containing beneficial and probiotics, such as new and healthy bacteria,
Helps the old bacteria grow healthily. Conversely, the fried chicken or other food you eat
Processed foods are treated with chemicals to kill bad bacteria, but at the same time unfortunately
Kill some bacteria that are good for you. In fact, Westerners are better than other cultures.
There are many microbial diversity, and people in other places mainly eat natural foods.
This is the processed food they eat, using antibacterial soap and
Caused by antibiotics. This also explains why Western culture has a high rate of allergies and
Autoimmune disease.
So when you worry about what you are, you have to
Remember that you can control these super biological cells. If you are tiny to you
Life is good, there is a good diet, they will take good care of you. Or at least... that ten percent
Really you...
Special thanks to Littlebits for its support of AsapSCIENCE. Littlebits is
These type of modular building blocks are for modeling and learning.
The best way to electronic. From simple sensors to LEDs to more complex wireless and programmable
In part, they can bring fun to everyone at the festival - whether you are a musician,
Programmers, gadget enthusiasts, or home project enthusiasts. You can learn more at littlebits.com.
Enter the code 'ASAP' to get a $20 discount on orders over $80 or more.
When you are done, remember to send your designs and projects via twitter or instagram!
To watch more scientific videos every week, please subscribe!